can you believe it's 14 years ago that
three-year-old madeline mccann
disappeared from a holiday resort in
prayer deluge in portugal ever since the
world has wondered what happened to her
and over the years developments continue
to happen in the case one man that has
been investigating ever since she
disappeared is john clark and he joins
us now hello to you john thanks for
joining us on the program i know that
you've written a book my search for
madeleine you were one of the first
journalists on the scene at the time
do you think first of all that she might
still be alive
morning kay uh it's nice to see you
again uh i would say there's a chance
that she's still alive and i know the
germans have called this a murder
inquiry but i'm going to stick with
operation grange and say it's a missing
person's inquiry still okay
take us back to 2007
uh well i got a very early call
goodness knows what time probably around
6 6 30 in spain and that would have been
about 5 30 in portugal and uh
i
as you know often away jump in the car
very quickly and and just got on the
road i was told there was a girl had
gone missing in portugal in in fact in
the algarve in a place i'd never heard
of called predaluge
and uh i expected her to be found by the
time i actually got there
[Music]
you know obviously as you know that
hasn't happened but uh
when i first got there it was quite
clear that uh it was fairly haphazard
um
the search operation and um i think
you've seen a photograph there that i
took of the very flimsy not this one
you're looking at now but another one of
the gates i was able to walk up the
steps and actually pop in and even
introduce myself that's the one to the
family
and i didn't have a long chat with them
just to say hello because they were
actually due to go off to report a
missing person's uh
case at the the police station so i i
just said look i'll do everything i can
to help i'm here for the mail and and
various other um broad newspapers and
and just got on my job uh as i always
have done what do you think happened to
her well i i think it's it's fairly
apparent and i've always thought this in
the beginning it looked very much like a
snatch from um
either alone or a pedophile gang to
order that had been studying the
apartment i think having looked at this
case now for 14 years as you say it
looks to me like there were people
watching the apartment and monitoring
her when she was there i think in my
book i point out two blonde head guys
who have seen
literally an hour or two before she went
missing on a balcony below
um or nearby very near the apartment and
nobody's ever come forward and worked
out who these two men were they were
seen by various people
i believe one of those was christian who
uh is now the current prime suspect uh
in the case and uh as of june last year
it's been a kind of mad scramble to
understand
you know what he was doing there and how
he was able to live there for seven
years when he'd been convicted twice of
of child pornography and indeed of
molesting children in germany and
i had many many other
cases against him in fact i i've traced
19 different convictions against him in
my book
uh and he was able to live for seven
years in predeluge just just
less than a kilometer from the ocean
club uh
somehow the police didn't think he would
be of interest to arrest and question
of course he denies the allegations
presently in prison for other offences
in germany um do you think we will ever
know we'll ever discover what happened
to her
i strongly believe that uh the german
police are a very good case against
christian beer how you want to call him
and they've been working on this since
2017
quietly behind the scenes that the
german police the bka and it was only in
2018 the prosecutor got involved and
they felt there was a very good case to
prosecute they worked behind the scenes
for two more years that's three years in
total piecing together
uh how do you put it all the evidence
they need to bring a successful
prosecution against him in the meantime
we mustn't forget that he was also being
probed on many other cases including the
rape of a 72 year old woman imprada luge
just two years before maddie went
missing and he's now been convicted of
that and has been given seven and a half
years in prison that's been ratified he
won't get out for four years so the
police have plenty of time to to to
further probe him on other cases has
been a horrible rape of hazel bear hand
that you spoke to exclusively at sky
news irish girl in 2004
very near same police force the same pga
department imported now they're
investigated and they've never solved
yes we're gonna have to leave it there
but it's always great to talk to you
john thanks for taking the time this
morning good luck with the book thank
you